everybody
so
it's a real pleasure to have a Christian
from Caltech so Chris is a is a first
year grad student at Caltech he's
working with Garnet Chan and John presco
um
the the book He's giving is based on
work he did in at UC Irvine as an
undergrad but he was working with Steve
White and he was also working with uh
miles dorton my who from the flat iron
Institute at the Simon's Foundation
and miles is going to join us as a
panelist after the talk so so Chris uh
looking forward to your talk
thanks Umesh for the introduction
um
okay
uh
right so hi everyone uh so today I will
be talking about this workout that the
quantiford transform passing small
entanglement which is in collaboration
with Miles Stoudemire from flighter
Institute and Cy from UC Irvine
um so start with a brief overview of our
work
so the Conifer transform is one of the
most important ingredients in Ghana
algorithms
however will show that uh the core part
of the qft can only generate small
entanglement on qubits and I will
explain to you about the core part and
small entanglement means
we can then simulate the qft classically
use intensive networks which can be
faster than fast forward transform in
many productive cases
but this is not a bad news for quantum
computers because it doesn't mean the
qft can be similar classically for
arbitrary inputs for example studying
short circumstance will have a expensive
tensor Network which I will also explain
a little bit later
oh so here is a brief outline so I'll
start with some introduction to the
Conifer transform and the related
Concepts
so the quantum floor Transformer has
been widely used in Quantum algorithms
for probable speed up over zero
classical counterparts and I said I said
the most famous example is the short
sales of factory integers and there are
a lot of other applications for tolerant
quantum computers
um so the quantity for Transformers
power stems from its ability to find
periodic structures of quantum stage
which many chronic algorithms rely on to
gain a pro ball speed up
so when we talk about Quantum food first
of all we usually mean over the cyclic
group uh this up to to the power of n uh
which is essentially the discrete for a
transform over here for space spent by n
qubits so in terms of Matrix we can see
this exactly the discrete for transform
Matrix where this Omega here is a phase
depends on the number of qubits
and in this bracket notation HQ is a bit
string formed by uh NQ bits
um so the quantum Circuit of the Fourier
transform can be decomposed into two
parts uh which I call a core part and
the bit reversal part uh so the core
part is essentially consists of Hardware
transport Gates and phase Gates
um and this thought here basically means
the control a control gate where if the
first qubit is zero you apply the kids
on the rest of qubits uh sorry you don't
apply the uh the gates and if the third
qubit is one you apply all these kids on
the rest of qubits
um and the second part is the bid
reversal is which is essentially swiping
the order of the bits so you can consist
of a series of swap Gates between the
first the last and the second uh the
second to last and so on
so from now on we'll actually refer Q as
the kmt and FN of the DFT which is which
means that uh I will only only care
about this uh sort of the core part and
drop the bin reversal and now we call
this part as carnivore transform
so entire circuit I will refresh the
description for transform of Matrix
um then I will talk about the main
results I will start with some informal
statements and then I'll gradually build
up the formal system of the our paper
so informally speaking what paper or
paper is supposed to show you that the
shimming coefficients of the qft and the
DFT actually differ significantly now
what if I assume about what I mean by uh
should be coefficients uh so it turns
out qn has an exponentially decaying
instrument coefficients for any
partition of the operator such as the
small entanglement this is our work uh
and the FN where we include the bid
reversal actually has a uniform swimming
coefficient for any partition of the
system uh and this is done previously by
uh in this two paper which suggests
maximum entanglement so that is most
entanglements in the full uh for return
store operator comes from the bid
reversal it's not the part where you
have the recursive structure
so why do we consider shimmy
coefficients so there are actually many
variants of operators you have a measure
um but we specifically consider operator
should be decomposition because uh the
usual they lower pump the non-local
communications required to implement the
operator it also indicates represent
representability as an efficient tensor
Network in particular matrix product
operator
um it often
they also capture the maximal
entanglement the operator can generate a
biparton makes column States so uh it's
not like the definition that is maximal
entitlement but often it's very close to
those and for our for the build reverse
operator we can see that it's a very
long local operation because it swaps
all qubit pairs between two subsets
subsystems and can generate large
entanglement or subsystems of your
Quantum States
so to be more formulated
oh we can we Define the operator
schmidty conversation of a unitary
Matrix that you know by partner system
um A and B as the decomposition of this
form
so we're a chi this number here is uh
the Shamir Rank and the sigma K here are
the Schmidt coefficients
and uh this operator A and B acting on
two substance subsystem will uh will
acidify some orthogonal property in the
space of the operators
and this big end here is essentially the
propane storm uh sorry squared of n
would be the frugalist norm of the unit
Matrix and because it's a unitary it's
essentially the product of the uh the
the dimension of two subsystems
and uh because we choose that we've uh
we have this actual Factor here uh the
shimmy coefficient are actually
normalized so usually when we're using
when we do this decomposition uh the the
coefficient are not normalized but
because of this uh constantly here uh uh
here where there's nice property that
they're normalized and also
um algorithm from the largest to the
smallest
so this is actually equivalent as the
singular value of decomposition just uh
like the shimited combination of a
Quantum state so we first reshape the
unitary into a matrix in the vertical
Direction so for example for this
interior here uh we bend the two wires
on the top to the same direction and the
wires uh of at the bottom to this same
direction which forms a matrix in the
vertical Direction and then we applied a
singular value completion to this Matrix
in a vertical Direction which would uh
we're broken into three parts and then
this is essentially a sum of our product
of two of operators that can uh two
subsystems
and uh they're orthogonal property of
these operators A and B I mentioned
essentially due to uh one of the a
singular value conversation we get the
isometric matrices sound for this A and
B as a
so uh just to have an example of the
operation with the conversation of a
swap gate is essentially the sum of
Polish so as we can see it has a maximum
rank which is four for two qubit gates
and it also has uniform chemical
equation which suggests uh it has
actually maximum
stress or like um
or like operator entanglements uh mostly
speaking and this expect why explains
why the bid reversal operator uh has a
very high operator intact but because it
consists of a lot of pairs of swipe
Gates
so uh for our main theorem of the paper
uh to to state it more formally we're
basically considering the streaming
decomposition of the operator qn and we
choose a partition of our uh operator uh
where are we uh the first uh the first
subset of a will be consists of qubits
one to J and since uh the other
subsystem B will consists with qubits J
plus 1 to end and in terms of the qn has
the human decomposition of this form uh
and for the streaming coefficients we
find that for K greater than or equal to
two uh it has this uh extremely fast
expansion decay
and it turns out this the Decay is
actually independent of the number of
qubits and partition of distance because
there's no dependence on n and J in this
Decay version so even if you have
infinite number of qubits for any
partition of the operator you still have
have you can still see this expression
Decay and just a side note here we
noticed that the red the Schmidt rank of
qfts is actually still expansionally
large so you know so it's just that the
Schumer coefficient Decay very quickly
very very fast
okay that was I'll actually talk about
before I go into details of how I prove
this and some other uh release stuff I I
will talk about some implications of
these results
so just a rough picture of what I just
said uh so what I was basically saying
is that the qrt has a high should be
ranked but uh some somewhat limited
correlation events and you you actually
only require a few biparted
complications to accurately approximate
the operator so basically means if you
partition the operator into two parts
most Communications between two parts
are somewhat truncatable
so does this result pose any complexity
hierarchy issues or so uh sadly or uh
heavily no because the classical similar
ability requires both operators and
states to have a small entanglements so
for example shorts actually has
especially expensive expensive State
before kfd so there's no non-classical
reputation of the states so even without
knowing all results which is queue up
this load entanglement some some of
early work already showed that uh
approximate qft is efficiently similable
if input circuit has limited interaction
range and mock depth uh or a log power
width which is the term used uh for the
graph of tensor networks and the
semi-classical qft is also efficiently
simulable so if the input state is
already cheap we actually don't need to
know anything about kept it's low income
for it to do to be simulable so
essentially all result doesn't add too
much in terms of computational
complexity
don't tell anything new on implementing
the kfdr from the computers so for this
I actually don't have a definite answer
um but I think some expert in the
audience might have a better view on
this but for me personally I think
generally it means that uh
low integument implies fewer resources
needed and it's also more robust to
noise
um however some can be architectures may
not favor input output to have a
different ordering so it really depends
on what kind of platform you're uh
implementing the economy for transform
it's also not clear whether it implies
the lower circuit depth because any qft
is approximate approximation error below
one or ten actually requires at least
log and depth so it's very hard to
reduce the uh the the depth of the
circuit based on the how much you
approximate the qft and uh and uh
there's a this login comment also
implied that there might be an
underlying especially decaying homophone
for the quantum for transform but it's
kind of hard to find it some opponent
and I will expand this uh India details
in later sections
so does it tell NC new on the classical
for transform uh so
um this sensory turns out to be yes
because uh for the low income manager
with the integument with the low income
of nature simulating the qft country
gain speed up or fast forward transform
in many classical albums so for example
if input is certain types of tensor
networks we're almost always favor uh
simulating qftr and over doing just not
you fast food transform so if input is a
vector we can still get Advantage if it
is comparable into certain test
standpoint so we can com convert into
some efficient tensor Network first and
then we can simulate kfd over it and
then we can still get some speed up and
I will explain with more details in some
in the later section
okay so then I will dive into uh some of
the methods I used to reverse improve
the decay of the shooting coefficient
and some of some intuitive explanations
of these results uh so the
sorry
so the
underlying mathematical reason for the
special decay of the key of the
instrument coefficients uh can be
understood through three steps so
firstly uh it turns out this uh
recursive Circuit of qn has a
generalizing recursive circuit from
which we can actually see that only
sophisticates are relevant to Schmid
coefficients
uh and from the face kids we find that
the streaming coefficients of qn are
actually equivalent to singular values
of the top left sandwiches of the PFT
Matrix so which I refresh FN
oh so the sum Matrix of DFT Matrix are
actually known to be approximately low
rank so they are extensively started in
Signal processing as uh the spectral
constant nutrition problem so this is
actually some something you can just
search online and there's a Wiki page
about this uh problem
so what is uh so let's let's talk about
the first step so what's what is a
generalized recursive case of
Destruction it can be circuits uh so
usually when we construct the recursive
part of the qft operator we usually
think about so we first construct the
qft for n minus one qubits and we apply
a bunch of control first grade on it and
then we apply eight hard markets on it
um so this is the usual the usual way to
construct the circuit however it turns
out it can be generalized into uh where
the H kits can be expanded into like uh
higher dimension in front of world
transform so essentially
um so this Edge case will borrow one
face gets from here and and educate from
this part and form a two qubit PFT and
with uh and this central part will
borrow some control physical to to this
part which forms a a
some more complicated structure here and
then this part will become a smaller
chronophore transform so here I choose
to show a 4 cubic example and I choose J
equal to 2 but you can imagine this
works for any number of qubits at any
partition so you'll always have this one
and for this central part uh you know
the the fiscuit you the face gates are
either central part only if and only if
it across the goes across the partition
of your system so it depends on the
choice of J
so because the two smaller TFT circuits
are locally interior interest respect to
respect to the partition
so we can say that only the central part
where the basically that goes across
partition uh is relevant to the uh
Schmidt coefficients so we can we only
need to focus on this part to tackle the
shipping coefficients
oh so let's take a look at what the
structure of the central part so it is a
operator that's diagonal is a
computational basis because of this or
control biscuits and it's metrics
elements are actually product of physics
conditions on the bit value of the two
registered so the upper register and the
lower register
so notice that I actually labeled 12
register in the opposite direction so
this will be useful later
um but you can see that uh it basically
introduced a phase that depends on the
big value of uh the it's like a complete
a relationship between the bit values
here of the two registers
uh so if we do some analysis we can see
that all this phase can be just combined
into a very elegant equation uh where it
only depends on the decimal value of the
register so it's there's no ratio of a
single based string so we just combine
obvious string into a single decimal
number and it's just uh this is a single
face here
and just to remind them we want to show
the space is actually related to the DFT
sub Matrix later in the step two
also just to summarize what I did for
step one basically I'm saying that for
corner for transform you can become
always decompose into three parts so
there are two parts as a smaller qfd
circuits which is irrelevant to our
analysis and there is a central part
which is uh uh a diagonal operator that
has diagonal elements that's uh somewhat
related to the the elements of the
screen for transform of and I call this
part as Sigma NJ and turns out the
coefficient of q n and card J is the
same of super coefficient of third Omega
NJ
uh so the so let's now take a look at
step two which is uh how this is related
to the uh sub Matrix of the screen for
transform uh so the non-zero system
coefficients of Sigma oh sorry Omega NJ
are actually equivalent to the singular
balance of some Matrix of that of the
DFT uh because if we do some calculation
we can see that we can solve uh what we
will calculate the sugar coefficients is
basically doing the singular values of
uh the reshape Matrix of this operator
so we combine these two uh into into a
into a single
and then because these are duplicate
Dimensions we can actually drop the
dependence of this and then uh we have
this nice operator here and this
operator is exactly just the uh two to
the power of J times 2 to the power of n
minus three sub Matrix of the discrete
for transform Matrix because instead of
something from 0 to 2 Pro 2 to the power
of n minus one here we have two drop J
and here we have two to the power n
minus J
so the sub Matrix so so let's now go to
step three which is uh uh why we know
this this has to be a low rank Matrix so
the some Matrix of the DFT are known to
be approaching low rank because it
relates to the spectral concentration
problem uh which has been exactly
started in Signal processing uh so the
original problem actually considers
discrete time for the transform but in
our case we use discrete Photoshop group
but nothing like it still uh have the
same spirit so the spectral
concentration problem basically wants to
find a strictly localized sequence in
this window here who's this great time
for transform is maximally localized
with a final window uh here it's a 2W
relative to the frequency periodic
window so it's a this larger window here
so the solution of this uh sequence are
known as this uh Sphero sequences so the
idea is basically so uh because this is
a finite uh window in the time domain
when we do this print time for transfer
we have this periodic structure and the
one to only focus on this periodic
window and what was selected a smaller
window here which uh I calculated the
sort of the power within this range and
want to vary the input to see you can
you can see that while there is the
input uh the signal will here will also
change drastically and the power in this
range will change and I want to just
keep varying the input until we find
that there's a sequence that gives the
maximum power within this range
uh
so we can actually uh so in our case
because we're using discrete type
display for Transformer it's actually
sort of a discretized problem of this uh
this uh original spectral concentration
problem
um so inside of a constraint to a
strictly localized time sequence we're
considering to be localized red to a
periodic window so this actually can be
viewed as a discretizing in the
frequency domain so it's it's it will
have this larger box let me just copy
this large box a few more times and uh
and uh here here you can already see why
this is related to some Matrix of this
workflow transfer because the
description Maps these larger blocks
into this larger block but here we only
focus on this smaller block and this
smaller Block in the time and the
friction domain
so with some of the analysis we can show
that uh essentially with some Maximum
maximization problem and uh actually
this can be uh directly mapped to a
eigenvalue problem or a single values of
the tfts top left sub Matrix
oh so what's the property of the sub
Matrix of the uh of the this peripheral
transform uh so for an R times C so R
refers to the number of rows and c times
reverse the number of coulombs some
Matrix of
um n by N D Squared for transform the
singular values actually have a
clustering Behavior so essentially you
have a sort of like pseudo degenerate
region uh where you have a r times C
divided by n number of again values
that's very close to one and after that
you have you see like extremely fast
extensional Decay here
uh
so remember for our qualifier transform
we always have this 2 to the power of J
times 2 power of n minus J some Matrix
so which means that uh only one single
value is actually close one and it's
also independent of the choice of uh J
and N because when we time this time
this number of rows and number of
columns together we got two to rough n
and if we divide by 2 0 Over N we get
one so it's basically for any J and N we
also we only have one single value is
close to one so we see this expression
Decay immediately so that's sort of the
reason that uh in our uh bound there's
no dependence on J and n and off
so to prove to prove this rigorously we
can use some practice that people use
signal processing has to develop which
employs the Decay property of half all
the best of functions and all these
interests you know details shall refer
to our paper to see uh how this derived
okay just to summarize so the shipping
coefficients of the qft are singular
values of DFT sub Matrix and D5
subatrics is related to the spectral
concentration problem
so spectral concentration has a decaying
solutions for Smalling to the kft's
decanishment coefficients and the upper
bounds are independent of the number of
qubits and the partition of the system
so let's now talk about something uh
more intuitive about the qft small in
common which is some relation to the
error law so uh it's still not included
why the kft circuit with the long range
Gates and non-local uh sorry
non-constant depths can have a small
entanglement so can we interpret the qft
as a physical process which is evolution
under somehowtonian with constant time
and understand the low intent from there
so uh there there are a huge amount of
literature that's uh sorting this type
of topic but uh uh there's a result
that's saying that every there's
aerological Dynamics but for Wendy you
can just interpret that for a
Hospitality or when the United if the
interaction range decaying faster than
vowel r squared then the hamiltonian
always has constant Integrity rates so
in other words no why evolving an
arbitrary 1D system with such hypotonin
the rate of the tape
change of the systems internal entropy
actually does not increase with the
system size so it seems that well
into this category so uh is this really
true
um so it turns out it's probably solving
the qfts hamiltonian is a very
challenging task because the hard
markets and control fiscuits uh do not
do not commute with each other
okay
however we call data from our previous
analysis that uh human coefficients are
actually only dependent on the fiscuits
so therefore if we remove all the hard
markets
the Chevy coefficients will actually be
invariant for any cut so in fact we can
show even more which is at any part
biparton embankment measure under the
local operation cluster communication
principle will remain invariants from
removing the hard markets
so this is actually very nice because
this hamiltonian is this operation is a
it's a diagonal operator and it's a it's
very easy to derive uh the uh the
underlying hamiltonian for this operator
so it turns out this hot component is
exactly a special Decay interaction so
even though we do not uh actually solve
the harmful for qft we can find a
homophones that have the same
entanglement structure with the kmt
sound running
um so this means that klt must have sort
of a similar Behavior but it's just that
the operators might be too completely
defined
okay
um and the lastly I will talk about some
work on uh doing the simulations of the
quantum foil transform
so uh the quantum floor plans for small
entanglement implies uh that it has an
efficient tensor enough for
representation so in particular uh
Matrix uh product operator
representation
uh so to find it we will first consider
uh decomposing the control fiscuit into
some lower local tensors
uh so I wouldn't talk in details but
essentially you can sync uh this control
fiscuit as a copy tensor until uh phase
tensors uh
and uh these copy texture basically
takes all three inputs of
uh or only evaluates what what three
inputs are the same and this basically
is only uh it gives a face when the up
when this top inducts and the horizontal
index or have those uh uh are both what
and this uh uh three order phase tensors
are evaluate okay it's only one the
so this actually allows us to decompose
the entire care of the circuits uh into
a pretty compact tensor Network which we
call the kfd national network of
so uh to efficient and construct the
kftmpo we can just view this entire test
network uh as a series of uh matrix
product operators and we can apply any
uh mpo and mpo multiplication algorithm
with spawn machine Capital constant
um to construct The Matrix for the
operator so we use the so-called
ziplocal works because it's both fast
and stable in our case due to some nice
property of the uh the space Gates
of
so I assume we set the bound dimension
of the kft and po2 tie the construction
contraction officer will generally have
a Time complexity that skills with uh
the uh the third power to the pump
version and the squared to this uh and
and script to the number of qubits and
the time complex and the constant
associated with this complexity is also
very small but for example for 50 qubits
and only you should take around one
second to construct the entire mpo
and the total truncation Arrow will
scale linearly with the number of Cupids
because we're doing truncation for all
kinds of the uh the operator
and a scale
the skill especially small with the
uh the the bond Dimension uh so for
fixed arrow is that this will fix this
damper the bond version will grow
sub logarithmet they call it
uh so this this is some of the marks on
the Arrow so in the uh in the column uh
there's a number of qubits will increase
from six to eight and uh you know sorry
in a row this is the number of cables
and in the column uh this is uh the bond
Dimension which we increase from two to
eight uh and we sort of calculate this
quantity to refer to represent our Arrow
so you can see that if we set both
version to eight uh you can't uh this is
actually already that's the machine
position so you can see there's already
fluctuation here because uh for for n
equals to A it will actually observed a
smaller Arrow compared to the previous
form so essentially for practical
purposes we can treat this as exact uh
or uh or we can say that the bond
version can be silver traded as constant
because it grows so slowly
uh so uh our kftmpo is actually
efficient uh enough uh to be classically
practical
so which uh we sort of called the super
festival for transform
oh so uh what I mean by that is that so
for example if the input is a matrix
product state with a bound to mentioned
uh chi M uh apply the kfd mpo on this
MPS uh will have a linear complexity so
it scale similar with number qubits uh
the bonding machine of the mpo and the
bond version of the MPS uh so if the
input is a vector of a lens and N to the
power of a big n to the power of the two
to the power of small n uh we can
convert it to MPS first using uh for
example randomized SPD which takes about
uh essential ways to double qubits but
the linear with the uh the bound version
of the online NPS so compared to fft uh
with type uh to uh linear with double
qubits we still have that end but
Advantage if the pawn Dimension is a sub
linear so for for example for constant
one dimension MPS we will always get
some advantage over by just doing this
style simulation
so we can even be faster by using more
efficient conversion methods such as
so-called tensor train crossing
compilation
uh so just to mention a few so here I
only think about the time of converting
MPS to sorry a vector to MPS because it
actually dominates the time of applying
both constructing the qft and applying
kfd on the uh MPS so we actually only
need to consider this part
so here are some benchmarks run on the
personal Chronicles or personal
classroom computer so for compressible
data we can already see that the
advantage of at around 18 qubits
um so this uh
um black line sorry so this green light
is the best for transfer so as we can
say it's independent of the the
structure of the input because it just a
multimeter is multiplication so it
scales around the essentially with the
level of qubits because it's a log skill
and uh here uh so the for the black
lines uh this is uh some randomly
generated data and we uh we we both
compare that uh we we started with a a
vector and convert into amps and apply
component for transform uh mpo on it and
as well as we start with MPS already and
just apply the kftmpo on it so as we can
see uh if it's a random data we don't
have an advantage at all because we
expect the MPS to have especially large
one dimension however for some more
structured functions such with some
periodic structure so even with some
tasks which is a is a dog where the
first derivative is non-continuous
um we can already see that uh there's
some Advantage even while including the
time of converting it to MPS first uh
and if we we start with MPS already is
this uh that is a solid lines we can see
that it has a sort of expression
Advantage compared to fast forward
transform
so this actually implies uh many uh
classical applications because of
operations with fast forward transform
become very cheap in Matrix broader
States so we can apply it to quantum
chemistry Quantum Dynamics uh
differential equations and so on so this
is a uh what I'm currently working on uh
so for example uh the photo
interpolation convolution uh La Plaza
which can be diagonized by photo
transform and also split operator uh
evolution in some Quantum Dynamics
problems
huh
so there's also evidence that uh the
binwise encoding or functions through a
major Explorer State and major Pro
operator is actually very powerful and
for personal resection in addition to
this family so we can actually combine
all of the to do fast classical
computations uh so some examples
including so many functions actually
have an explicit efficient construction
as a small rank Matrix part of States so
for example uh cosine is special uh
final order polynomials can be directly
converted into electric power states
where we can write out the elements of
each tensor individually
and uh this uh something uh usually
self-similar functions uh also have this
uh behavior of a heavy small bar
dimension when converted into MPS
so there's also evidence that uh
probably all the lipsticks continuous
functions uh have a small Bond version
where Loosely speaking this just means
that the uh the derivative is bonded by
some sort of constant
um
so uh for bitwise operations and final
step machines we can also directly uh
convert them into uh efficient appeals
for example uh the the rip uh some
addition uh just a ripple carry Adder
for example and also some shifting
operations
um
we can we can directly write out the
elements for each local tensors in the
mpo
oh so just uh just a side note this so
this is this was something I um I didn't
realize when I was writing the paper but
uh another question to ask is uh whether
uh the same low rank structure applies
to the approximate humility which is
something people have been studying a
lot in the uh part of computing
Community which is defined by removing
the long-range control phase Gates
um so for example for the approximation
so with zero approximation I always have
the first secret full circuit uh for a
approximation level with one uh you
remove the longest uh the control phase
case with the longest interaction range
and the appropriation two you remove uh
uh this uh of a filter
so numerical simulation is actually just
that the matrix product operators for
this approximate qrt actually have a
higher bound Dimension uh which is
actually quite a counterintuitive
um and this was a sort of privacy uh
found in this paper by uh Kieran and uh
the lower rank structure seems to be a
feature of the key of this full circuits
uh so uh
um I I don't have a rigorous argument
for this yet but I just think this is
something that is interesting to no
okay uh and then I will uh end with some
future art looks
uh so firstly I will I'll
um I'm curious about is that the weather
of Israel is not really imply a better
position of security on quantum computer
so for example there are some relative
work where we can convert The Matrix
Department States into a Quantum
circuits so can we do the same for the
Matrix for the operator by sort of for
example minimizing an interview with the
minimize the distance between unitary
with the main tmpo uh and for analog
quantum computers we can also try to see
if we can type evolving an external
decaying homophonian with constant time
to construct the uh krld operator
so second question is just what I just
said is that the approximate converter
boy does approximate Quantum for
transform seem to have a higher
entanglement than the full circuit
Contour transform uh can we generalize
this result to more General groups
uh and the can we also find more
classical applications of results and
can we even categorize a general class
of classical problems where we can
employ the structure of this qrt appeal
and to achieve some speed up or fast
forward transform and lastly we cut as
whether we can conduct this qftmpo to
other uh faster for transform so for
example the previous post frame is the
spots for transform which says that if
your uh if uh your friction domain is
only have a few uh spikes you can sort
of achieve expansion speed up with some
cases so is there any relation uh
between all these different types of
faster forward transfer
oh
so uh with that I will end with some
acknowledgments so thanks for Milestone
ISD white it was an amazing
collaboration and thanks for sending
Sean Mark Connor chin and chain group
for the Excel for discussions on the
classical applications of the results
thank you for the adaptation
[Music]
okay wonderful all right thanks for a
really nice talk
um it was very
um very stimulating I I guess in a in a
certain sense you could you could you
could almost say well if you leave aside
the open questions about how how to
speed up uh the quantum Fourier
transform quantumly this is almost like
um uh you know one one aspect of your
results is it's a it's a Quantum
inspired classical algorithm yeah
yeah exactly and then there's something
else that that occurred to me which
maybe we can discuss further in the
panel which is you know obviously you
think of the bit traversal as being you
know I mean if you just think about it
it's it's not entangling the state very
much but but as an operator it is so you
know exactly where where it stands with
respect to the role that entanglement
plays in Quantum computation maybe we
can tease it out a little further about
you know maybe we have um we have to
think about the right definitions or you
know what what we think of of there but
uh
um in the meantime um yeah let's let's
see if there are any other questions
before we move to the panel
so Frank uh I guess uh yeah you can you
can just speak up and
um you can also speak on the panel I
guess but uh actually I have a question
about uh yeah the the the talk really so
so so two questions actually first of
all the approximate one two three
transform so this is the way I have
always looked at this is that this is
already a mate Explorer operator
approximation of the quantum free
transform so uh in which the bond
Dimension is basically the number of of
as exponential the exponential of the
number of digits that you keep so so how
much worse is that because then you
don't even have to compress anything you
immediately have a matrix product
operator approximation of the control
free transform up to a certain Precision
so how much worse is that one than than
your compression right uh so I think
that depends on how much approximation
level you make so if you make the
professional level like relatively large
I guess uh because you can see that
converted that I could drive here you'll
have a pretty small body version then
you'll notice uh but if you for example
you don't have approximation level one
uh for like if you increase the
yeah because the approximation level
here I use is just removing against
instead of the number of control phase
kit I use so for example if I have a
larger system you'll you only remove one
and you still expect this increasing the
bond Dimension I guess yeah but you have
to it's it's at the end it's about the
scaling you know and and if you if you
look at the scaling uh you you only say
Okay I want to approximate things up to
machine Precision that also means that
you don't that that you only keep a few
kind of of the qubits so the
approximation level is not the right
kind of of of of of measure to look at
so we just say Okay I I only keep the
qubits that that act on a range let's
say of five or ten cubles or something
and that gives you a million MP of one
dimension two to the ten yes yes exactly
so that's actually softly the range of
uh uh so it's like about about here so
you can see it at here so for example if
you keep up to five it's sort of like
this point you can see it's still sort
of constant I guess this this sort of
reflects that a little bit even though
it's not directly relative that to to
like uh converting that you have lpo
does it make sense
or yeah not complete but actually I have
a second question if you if I may so
what about the the the the fermionic
Fourier transform because then you
actually have to act on kind of swap
Gates does that change anything in your
in your analysis yeah I think I believe
that changed a lot so uh there was a
previous program like spectral tensor
Network on this uh formula transfer for
transform but if you look at look at it
what it does it's actually a much more
complicated uh operation than just now
we call them for transform because it
contains like both one particle two
particles three particle cases and
mixing it into a large operation and uh
there's also a lot of non-local uh
subjects so in that case like even I
think even we drop the fermatics updates
it doesn't have a lower rank structure
at all
so and then I'm confused about the
application in quantum chemistry because
for this you need a fermionic Fourier
transform
ah I see so
um by that uh for
um right so for in front of so by that
is it's more like uh what would you for
example if we want to do hardship for
calculation uh there's there's for
example the color operator we can use
that to sort of like uh we can use
flexible transform we can approximately
a common Loop uh convolution with this
vertical transform using uh this
convolution theorem for example so
that's what I sort of made by
application we call the chemistry it's
not like apply for beyond for a
transform
okay great um so uh Stefan do you want
to wait till we are on the panel or we
can just do the questions from the Q a
and then move to the panel would that be
okay sure okay okay so uh
so Chris there's a there's a question on
the on the uh okay uh sorry and if you
can stop sharing you know there's a
question on the Q a uh you can see
thanks for the very nice and clear talk
can you comment on your classical qft
and hero method how it compares to the
qtt Ft method by dolgov so um for their
results they are basically saying that
uh if you give give MPS I can just
directly simulate the cavity by applying
the circuit uh layer by layer on the MPS
so it's like uh if we go back to uh
let's see uh
if we look at the
um
right so these slides here so what they
are saying is that instead of converting
this in person as a single mpo I apply
this appeal first down by uh more State
and then this mp1 right there and then
there's some people mistakes so the
problem with their firmal cassette you
cannot really guarantee what's the uh in
common wasting uh between uh applying
this mpos so by showing the entire kft
has a a small town but we can sort of
have a guarantee on that how much and
however the entire thing can be
generated and it's also a relative more
inclusion because there's no
fluctuations of the environment about
applied the sqft uh with between this
appeal so it's like we can compress the
internal operator first and apply it
directly on the states
great yeah okay thanks um
so let's see um yeah Chris if you can
stop sharing your slides then sure look
at the panel
uh
okay so uh let me start um introducing
the panelists uh Frank vestrate you you
already you already heard from a little
bit uh you know Frank um just moved I
think from Ghent University to
University of Cambridge he's um he's
done really fundamental work in the
entanglement of uh Quantum many body
systems including defining peps which
are you know beautiful model uh we have
uh Milestone who is uh he's uh
he's one of the co-authors of the paper
he's at the flat iron Institute at
Sammons foundation so he's uh he he's
done this incredible uh work on uh using
tensor networks to uh you know to model
sort of uh chemically accurate effects
temperature effects and he's also
responsible for this items software
and um and we have Stefano's uh Curtis
from the University of Sherbrooke uh so
he was um he was a course on this recent
paper which on tetsu network contraction
which gave uh sort of five to six orders
of magnitude speed up
um uh you know that was used in the
Google
um uh the the the
spoofing classical algorithms for for
the Google Supremacy experiment and all
the follow-up experiments so really
great to have you all here um maybe
um we start with um with your reactions
to the paper and maybe also Stefano you
had a question so maybe you can wrap it
all into into your comment
sure yeah so uh thanks Chris for the the
awesome talk I really I really like this
paper I uh so Miles a couple weeks ago
um at a workshop in in New York and I
conveyed my enthusiasm to him as well uh
I have one specific question
um
regarding the spectrum of the DFD
so the spectrum of the DFT looked flat
most of it was flat except for an
exponentially decaying part and I'm
wondering whether
um even though you have volume low
entanglement the the fact that the
spectrum is flat tells you that there
might be some simplification that is not
evident
because for example
um if you have if you look at stabilize
or Clifford circuits you get slot
entanglement that can be volume low and
yet you have efficient classical
simulation algorithms when you have this
entanglement structure could you comment
on this could there be some underlying
structure one can exploit even to
decompose the TFT
in a certain way
I see that's a very interesting question
um
so um I guess like when we flat is it's
also referred to the some Matrix of the
fdm it's like uh there's so um so in the
case of qfd it's a little bit subtle
because you don't actually have that
flat region because you you have you
will say that it decay is immediately
but if you have a different partition of
the the photo transformation
but I actually don't really know if this
is really worth it to
um
if there's any way to sort of employ
this uh to sort of like
um flash to sort of go across this uh
flat region
um
because
because uh because I think I think I
don't I don't see a direct connection
between like this uh
um DFT for uh some Matrix with with what
you said about like you know you know
good for circuit or so because of
um
it's uh yeah it's a it's a little bit uh
I think I just said I don't know the
answer to this question yeah
I went back on that I agree with your
points upon us like that um if you just
made a for example if you take a state
if you just make a random MBS random
State and then you try to decompose it
look at it Schmidt Spectrum it will
generically Decay I mean as you know
um so then you would think you know flat
would mean something like more
specialist going on
like there is structure you would think
exactly so I mean if you pick a like a
random Vector interactive SVD it
um then you you you will get that
marchenko Pastor right so yes yes you
will get like a power load Decay you'll
get a an exponential number
um of non-zero uh Schmidt values but uh
they are distributed a certain way and
they Decay
algebraically and this is the the Decay
that we saw or like the behavior that we
saw in that spectrum is very different
it's like a flat for a certain uh time
and then just decays exponentially so I
was thinking maybe maybe that this is a
this is interesting something in tells
us that there's something interesting
some simplification
could be possible that is beyond just
um
you know just the the typical you know
SVD or matrix product uh structure
and um in fact I was wondering if if one
could like generalize this your approach
in this work and say well let's look at
any classical algorithm write it in
terms of an operator
um acting on on bits and then look at
the Spectrum
um so so basically uh it could be like
Quantum inspired anything uh right so
you you look at any algorithm you write
it as an operator or try to decompose
and see at the see if the singular value
Spectrum reveals something some
simplification that you missed
foreign
spectrum is actually always a
consequence of symmetries and of course
in the quantum free transform it's
really like this is the this is the
transformation you have to do to
diagonalize uh your or to find the eraps
of your group and of course it's like it
is very much tied to to to to symmetries
and that's why if you would do this for
indeed this more general question and if
you don't do the quantum free transform
for U1 but for a general group these are
these sure while transforms you will get
something very very similar you will
always get these kind of huge
degeneracies of Schmidt's eigenvalues
and this is actually all a consequence
of the of of of of symmetries and your
uh uh in your system
and and actually this this is something
that this typically if you do Matrix
block State calculations uh this is
always something very interesting if you
see the generacies in your spectrum it
it means that that maybe you have
something like topological order in your
face or this is all this witness is
something something interesting going on
on your in your state I'm not sure that
this this this makes things clearer to
you but but indeed the generacies are or
typically
hand in hand with with symmetries so
it's not a coincidence that is that
these the generacies are there
yeah I would just say that uh this uh
this interesting
um property of this uh have a leverage
and Decay problem and then like another
front Regional but zero single value is
like oh people are still trying to sort
of understand this uh the reason of this
I think like in Signal processing and
you know because this spectral kind of
training problem is actually sort of a
very fundamental problem and there's
actually no no like
so so I think it's still sort of like uh
people are still trying to find out like
more General algorithm what is this and
I think you will probably do some
interesting answers to uh some of the
questions you know
foreign
so could I ask also something uh
unrelated I would like to get this out
of the way right because uh I don't know
if we have any number of theorists in
the room but uh and he also commented uh
briefly on on Shore's algorithm but uh I
wanted to like follow up just to make
absolutely sure so
uh so in the case of semi-prime
factoring okay uh where you need to run
the full Shores algorithm
um to get to get an answer could there
be like some subset of semi-primes for
which uh entanglement could be low
um
running the full Shores algorithm that
we didn't identify before like a
subcategory of semi-prime factoring for
which which
um we can have an answer more
efficiently say than the best uh field
sieve classical methods for factoring
Chris do you want to take that
so uh I don't know too much about that
but like uh the impermanent in shorts
exam is like uh usually you will see
that in the mountain version is actually
approximating to the uh the period you
actually try to fight so it's like
um
um but I think I think it's like this is
sort of like a generic Behavior so I
guess uh uh it's probably like only it's
it's only dependent on the material
you're trying to fight so I'm not sure
if uh that's sort of like you can't have
a you know a sneaky way to go across
this it's probably not you know not very
possible
okay thanks I I suspected as much but um
I just wanted to to have a absolutely
clear clear answer on that thanks
so can I ask another question
sure so
um so something that is very interesting
and and where Fourier transforms are
used all the time in in in physics
simulations is is for things like like
gross speed isk equations okay you have
to kind of evolve non-linear
differential equations and
um it includes laplacians um and things
like that and well this is very annoying
to to to implement the discretize and so
further but but but things like like
laplacians are very easy to to implement
in in the Fourier world uh so is this
something have you have you looked at
application like this because this would
be the first thing I would I would try
to do like does this leads to can I
solve something like the the the the the
gross pitayevsky in a much more
efficient way using your your methods
because that's that's the kind of that
that's the kind of Dynamics this is what
you do now you you go to momentum space
Implement your library or your
derivatives then go back to real space
Implement your kind of potential uh and
and react with your potential on it is
this this is is you have you have you
tried this or is this the kind of things
you want to do or
yeah for uh yeah so even for like for
example even for like some uh simple
simulation like uh time dynamics of a
particle you have this uh LaPlace
operator and you can if you connect you
represent everything is MPS you can't
have this uh you can use security and
build a map into the diagonal oh sorry
in the forward space and now you can
have a uh which is uh basically a x
squared function in the forward space
and that you can map back and you can
have this low run structure but actually
even without kfd there's a in this
actually I'm queuing and pure encoding
of Laplace and you can find a different
method is already known to be no run so
it's just a try diagonal for example if
you use a order three you find a
different message you have this try the
Matrix which you can directly construct
the mq representation of that uh so I
think it's it's more about the whole
story of like having uh what's the
framework of like converting everything
to this mpu and do conclusion within
this uh this framework uh so it has a uh
so I think people have been exploring uh
using this to do higher order
differential equations and so on it's
like uh it's a relatively active
research
foreign
listed some functions that are known to
have very low Bond Dimension like an
exponential or a sign or a cosine in
real space but then immediately this
result about the Fourier transform NPO
means that if it's slow Bond Dimension
and K space like smooth or has some
simple structure in case space then it's
also a long dimension in real space it
just provides a very tight link
between those two spaces as well
automatically
yeah
you know for example an interesting
example is a circular Matrix can be
diagonalized by Fourier transform so if
you're a single your circular circular
Matrix have some nice property in the uh
for the origin values you can actually
simulate the circumators in this mpo
setting where relatively easy
and ask a follow-up question on that
sorry yeah so uh which is uh there is a
something that is a little being debated
in the uh Quantum Computing Community
when you use quantum computer to solve
classical or Quantum differential
equations involving unbounded the
differential operators right so one
thing that the quantum computer has a uh
uh the power is to resolve a huge number
of grid points with a logarithmic number
of qubits but of course when you uh for
like if the smoothness of the underlying
function is bounded by some constant you
you kind of expect that at the end of
the day I mean you will pretty much uh
going to resolve it either cut I mean
either quantumly or classically so does
your result or generalization of this
kind of thing imply there is a better
world way to design classical algorithms
to match this superpower by quantum
computers as well
yeah I think uh
it doesn't
um directly imply that but if someone
suggest this can be a good road to like
do some classical because uh
um so in principle you can basically map
any non-determinants Finance State
machine with sort of like constant uh
translation number of transitions to
this mpo setting and uh and but you have
the power of compression so it's like
you don't have to go to the full rank
space you can you can still always form
singular values that's something you can
employ it to sort of do this for example
for the smooth functions uh even though
it might have uh like uh for rank you
can still have like several way most of
the singular values so I think uh
uh yeah so it I I wouldn't say it's like
it's a
it's uh like directly implying that but
um it's I guess it's uh suggests that we
can try to see uh what's the power of uh
doing competition with this framework so
so to be uh more uh completely I mean
there's something I don't know how to
think about this problem let's say if we
do Dynamics
um and the SEO evolve your Dynamics the
function can often become uh more and
more Down Smooth right which means that
to the bond Dimension should the
presumably increase so on the quantum
computer uh
the the cost should pretty much be the
same and the classical computer the
cosmic may become higher and higher so
if they're uh do you think this
difference will always be there or there
is a some sort of way to uh make the
classical simulation more efficient to
even bridge this Gap
um I see I think certainly something
analogous can be done on the classical
side to what's being done in the kind of
if you want second quantized framework
where we have MPS for 1D but then you
use peps for 2D and it might you know be
further or like use a mirror or things
like that I think so far this technology
has mostly just been explored at like
The NPS level but there's certainly
potential to try other tensor networks
that can capture more entanglement
that's one
um another relevant thing to your point
I don't know if you've seen this work by
uh gorionov at all and it's like deta
reaction and some others where they
simulated The navier Stokes equations
using this exact same framework for
representing functions and for
representing differential operators and
things like that and what's really
interesting is they find
um that indeed it's just like you said
it's very smooth velocity field at the
beginning then it gets more and more
turbulent and there's more vortices and
things developing and the entanglement
grows but it's still actually very
modest and they find that it actually
really closely corresponds to the
Reynolds number so they find that the
more the higher the Reynolds number the
more entanglement you need also they
find a difference between 3D fluids and
2D fluids so there's all kinds of
interesting
hints there at like more of a theory
maybe roughly analogous to alveolic area
law for Quantum systems it's sort of
like a something like that but for
classical functions embedded into
Quantum States as tensor networks
interesting so this is still the qtt
type of study right yeah as in the
previous qia question that's right but I
think there's a lot more uh to do that
has already been done I mean I think
we're at the very early days of that now
I see thank you very much this is very
helpful
right so so Umesh had a power outage you
know you know the weather in Berkeley is
quite crazy right now uh so I am just
stepping in to moderate uh I can confirm
that
yeah so I think he's running to his
office so he might be online soon but
I'm happy to moderate uh meanwhile
um
I don't there's maybe one question on
okay the Q a question has already been
answered
questions comments by the panel
so so what about 2D fully transforms is
this something that that this has like
an efficient people description or
something is that is that that you look
at this right so um for 2D for transfer
is just a tensor product of two one B uh
for a transform so for example if you
think about uh say for example you can
think about you encoding your function
into a two by n apps uh and it's it has
degree Freedom password so it's a
current standard to give a function and
you can just apply it to tensorflow or
NPO on each each row of the peps to sort
of simulativity for a chance
but that means that you would you would
generate lots of entanglement with this
um you would get an area law of
entanglement basically just a quick
comment there it's like you don't really
need a pep still here to represent the
2D function right you could just use it
like an MPS with double sight Dimension
so yeah yeah you just have an X index
and a y index on each MPS tensor if if
by two different you meant like a
function of two variables if that's the
2D that you met
yeah yeah it's difficult to to to to to
to understand but I I figured that they
would get something like a instead of an
NPO you would get something like a paper
but maybe that's not maybe this is naive
so you say that
yeah you should usually if you think
yeah for 2D function it's like it's I
think it's not from mps2 perhaps it's
more like you have a few like uh it's
for example 2D you have two two times of
number size for your MPS and three days
three times because the dimension
because the grid points uh grows
expansion with the number of uh sites
you have so
um so for example you can encode your
MPS for example you can just uh uh link
to MPS to represent your ampere of 3D
function or you can single some clever
interlacing uh some in covering
interlacing between the side points for
example the first side represents uh
encoder the web the the functioning when
the the points in one D and the second
point of side surfing code something 2D
and third side is like interlacing or
like other arrangements that might lead
to lower entanglements yeah but but
anyway I think I think the the reason
that there is this this whole talk is is
to to see what is now really Quantum to
to this quantity transform because it
seems that more and more things that we
all believe that West Quantum is
actually not not really Quantum no that
these stats and networks are kind of
doing lots of of things so so you have
kind of a complete fresh perspective on
all these on all these questions I think
as a starting PhD student so what what
is your feeling so what is so so so why
why where will quantum computers be
useful for uh if if yeah what what what
are the kind of what is the really
Quantum kind of partner or let's say
shorts algorithm where is this hidden
now because because everybody's always
saying well this is the Quantum free
transform but that's obviously not true
right
um
so I think I think so
um so I think for quantum computers it
has the power to sort of just ignore the
entitlement that doesn't care about it
well classical is like so a lot of
problem is sort of avoid avoidable but
there are a lot of cases where you can
see that for example in this case uh you
can say there's some underlying
symmetric structure or whatever it's
like allows you to have employees low
rep structure but it wouldn't like
um I think this class is like people are
still trying to find different words
what are really these functions or
whatever where these operators are and I
think it will be really interesting to
generally as answering these questions
but uh
yeah I think it's just uh that people
are just discovering more and more uh
operators that uh actually have an
underlying uh structure that doesn't
generate this uh uh huge entanglement
somehow you know
yeah I mean I really like that question
because to me it says something roughly
like that
exactly as Chris said you need the
quantum computer when you expect to have
high entanglement but now we see at
least if you're in this function
representation use of your qubits it's
like high entanglement might mean
something like a function which is
highly not smooth like maybe something
which is a sum of Delta functions and
the Delta functions are at like totally
random locations in your Continuum maybe
something like that like that's the kind
of thing that you just simply cannot
represent classically this way
efficiently but then even functions that
have like a fractal structure which
Chris Christmas slide those can be
actually low Bond Dimension like quite a
few things can be really low bonded in
chin um in this representation low
entanglement
um sorry I missed a part of the
discussion I you know we had a power
outage in our neighborhood but uh back
on campus so I I wonder whether whether
you discussed some of this but um uh you
know there were there were two things
that that occurred to me you know one is
of course uh to what extent you know do
these uh tensor Network methods
um you know
uh you know to to what extent do they do
they uh really speed up classical
algorithms uh more generally
but then there's a there's a second
thing you know which is this this um
looking at the low entanglement piece
for for classical function
um so to what extent is this happening
in deep learning or you know where
you're looking at this corner of
function space so have you thought about
these these sorts of connections
I think it's a good connection to make
because there's already some really nice
work
um by some of some of the same people
actually who invented this technology
this tensor train framework uh some of
the same people tried putting
um basically it's like the analog of the
2D function in this representation as
the weight layer of a neural network a
priori like putting it in before they
knew the right weights then training you
know doing back prop uh through the
weights in that always staying in that
form and they found that they could
reach close to state of the art
performance of the neural net while
having a huge compression of the number
of parameters that needed I don't think
it's widely used in the machine learning
field but it's a really nice idea and it
seems to work
and do you think in addition to being an
idea that works do you think it has
explanatory value you know in terms of
um I think so at least in that case
because there's a whole toolbox then to
analyze those functions efficiently you
have this huge weight layer but you have
it compressed so you could you know with
this qft mpo that Chris came up with you
could um you could do a spectral
analysis for example but many other
kinds of kind of the whole entire
applied math toolbox can be recast in
this compressed form it turns out like
Chris mentioned differential operators
like so many things so you can kind of
bring the whole that whole toolbox onto
it
but what's nice about it say in that
case would be I guess in sort of very
rudimentary kind of deep learning like
if you didn't have any sort of
convolutional structure imposed it was
just an arbitrary weight later I think
there's a general freedom for the
weights to sort of connect up any way
they want however the Dynamics of the
gradient descent would want but if you
pre-imposed this kind of compressed form
you would have pre-imposed an ordering
to those you know qubits now which are
like the weights and so I think that
would at least give you more of a hope
of interpretability because you kind of
demanded this ordering so that you stay
in this low rank space the whole time so
at least you kind of could reconstruct
things a little better without having to
like do a bunch of swaps afterward to
sort of figure out what the weight layer
was maybe there's already other ways to
find a better ordering I'm not an expert
on that yeah so what what I would find
very interesting is to to uh to see
whether there's some underlying
principle of of like what functions can
you efficiently represent with matrix
product states in the sense that these
are functions that are like eigenvectors
of something like local yeah something
that is local okay something this is
exactly the the the whole point of
matrix product states of course in in
how Quantum hamiltonians is that that if
your Quantum homophone has a local
structure and the ground state is
basically a matrix products data there
should be some underlying some very
similar property for for all the
functions that you can represent
efficiently using these matrix product
States and what is very nice of course
is what what what what this work shows
that you have this function can be
represented and also the Fourier
transform of that function has an
efficient representation and and all the
kind of things that you do has like like
in it it's it's all it's all uh it's
it's it's it's it's all consistent but I
think something like that is completely
lacking we don't understand at all what
is the like like what is the underlying
principle of the functions you say okay
maybe all lip shits I forgot you said
this in
is there a notion at all yeah I think
there's a notion now that all these
functions have actually very few Fourier
coefficients or something that that is
that is known but um but there should be
more than that
yeah I do think this is a very timely
question as we briefly discussed earlier
I remember about 10 years ago I heard
the call romsky and uh from Mark plunk
and talking about this thing which is uh
using this uh qtt format to compress the
hard drive calculation to do enormously
large dense grids and now it seems like
a little bit ahead of his time but
indeed a lot of the foundational things
have been built there and given that
recently there is this Google
collaboration paper talking about the
stimulation of the exact Quantum
Dynamics compare that with the classical
Midfield methods but the speed up is
really come from this uh almost
exponential increase in number pervasive
functions and so so whether you can do
that uh do something that is better from
a classical perspective by understanding
the entanglement of this classical part
of the basis functions that's a it seems
to be a very very interesting question
by the way I think that's totally right
on on the money and I mean kromsky was
really way ahead on a lot of this stuff
so um highly recommend this work but one
nice thing too when we mentioned
chemistry it made me think that um a
really nice uh kind of basis set to use
is just a grid because it's like
automatically orthogonal and has a lot
of nice properties
um but often you know grids don't scale
too well and this what's kind of nice
about this approach is that you are
implicitly using a grid representation
but then you're compressing it so you
get like a lot of the advantages of
using a grid but you sort of don't have
as many other disadvantages of using it
in like a naive way so that's one kind
of potentially exciting thing about this
this way of representing functions too
that's right yeah I mean uh with a grid
you have a lot of other good properties
as well especially when we go to
interacting chemistry and with this
diagonal representation yeah those are
definitely very very useful techniques
so Umesh I also wanted to go back to
your question about the the swap kind of
circuits why this is so entangling so
this is of course well known this is
like the the kind of of quantum
information questions that people looked
at more than 20 years ago uh is like
like what are the most entangling Gates
and indeed the most entangling gate that
you can have is a swap operation
although a swap on itself will not
generate entanglement if you apply it to
a product State because if you have two
like maximum tangle States and you swap
these two qubits then you generate
immediately two times like yeah you you
generate like two two bits of
entanglement and this is indeed somehow
the reason that that is this swapping of
of your gazes is indeed so hugely
entangling there's nothing there's
really it's only interesting if you if
you swap things that are already
entangled with other things like that
yes and in that sense it's indeed
completely useless entanglement if you
if you're not entitled with something
else
um so so by the way this was also like
the the big problem this this whole idea
that that swapping is actually can
generate lots of entire and it was was
was a big problem in in in trying to
formulate like the the question how much
entanglement can be created under under
time Evolution uh like under under time
Evolution I think it is also briefly
talked about this and you you talked
about this in your in your talk now you
suggested that indeed the fact that that
your Quantum free transform does not
generate lots of entitlement because
there is indeed like a an entire a
hamiltonian with exponentially decaying
terms that that that that cannot
generate lots of entanglement because
exactly because of this this this this
this way how much entanglement can you
create with such research swaps and all
this and this this there's no complete
kind of picture uh of of of how this
works but this was very so the the the
the the difficulty in proving all this
is exactly to get rid of the swap type
of of arguments
that's right it's kind of like a
entanglement distillation argument uh
almost because
um you can have maximal entanglement if
you spread Bell pairs across a cut you
will get the maximum maximum
entanglement but that's that's trivial
right
and so this is why when I see a flat
Spectrum I'm wondering is there a way to
distill just belt pairs and just throw
them out of the computation
um
and uh and just to only do the relevant
part
yeah if I might comment on this this is
exactly what happens actually with with
with tensor Network algorithms where you
exploit symmetries
this is exactly you don't like if you
have something like an Su 270 miles an
hour is this very well you have like an
su-2 symmetry you you basically don't
care about your
you only get about your 6j symbols let's
say about about your your
representations your labels of
representations not about your magnetic
quantum numbers okay these these because
the entanglement that is generated by
these quantum numbers is the one that
give rise to your flat spectrum and
these are not interesting so you can
have a huge speed up in in in
simulations by indeed taking advantage
of the fact that you know that there's
lots of of flat pieces that they have
lots of degeneracies and this is exactly
what is being done when you when you
simulate when you use symmetries in in
in tensor network uh algorithms but what
is even more things like like things
like the toric codes okay if you look at
this this also has like a very flat
Spectrum well this is like a hamiltonian
that is well it has an area law of
entanglement but effectively if you look
at it in some way this is just a product
State it's a product state in in a basis
of of gauge functions okay so you can
really kind of see this as a product
state if you impose the right symmetry
or to your to your wave function and I
think this is exactly the direction that
you want to go to now that I need like
something like the 30 code is actually
has zero entanglements if you look at it
from the point of view of symmetric
tensor Networks
yeah but I think it must be beyond what
we call symmetries in physics right like
the the typical symmetries because you
can write stabilizer states without any
symmetry right any any physical space
Symmetry and it's in fact the
non-stabilizerness or like sometimes
people unfortunately call it quantum
magic that um actually generates
non-triviality uh
and so so yeah that's I completely agree
it's just that if you have something
like a some translation variance or so
for this case it's understood uh I think
this is this at least an indication that
what you say is indeed uh it can be
realized
if I can go back to the to the quantum
inspired uh side meaning uh the
classical simulations is now that you
are unconstrained by unitarity and all
other things imposed by the quantumness
are there any other
um speed UPS you can imagine
um in the in the classical simulation of
the uh the qft that would allow you to
do things even faster and here I'm
thinking maybe something like amortized
gaining some amortized amortization
[Music]
uh speed UPS like if you want to Fourier
transfer many many uh functions at the
same time
um
could this be could this be somehow uh
exploited like you sometimes in deep
Nets when you have convolutional layers
and so on you mentioned convolution at
the end of the talk also
as a potential Target
um do you have any thoughts on this how
to go further
right
um
I think I think actually I feel like
this is just a very first step of
understanding this moving home
construction of qrt because uh their
sector is still a lot of interesting
part of the community that I I were like
we weren't really able to solve like for
example
um
like when we increase the increase the
number of qubits you actually see all
the logo tensors approach to themselves
so they have sort of like a self-similar
structure in within the tensors uh so I
think in order to sort of enter a
question I guess so
um I personally feel it it has to be
like understanding like what's really
going on to to like be like underlying
for this low income link like uh low
impairment structure of the kft so um
yo
so it also really connects to like a lot
of other algorithms that uh as mentioned
like the sparse Warrior transform where
because if you if you have a just a few
four coefficients you will also uh think
that the four transform of uh so uh if
you only have a few for for a
coefficient you also have a efficient
Matrix Bond uh State repetition of that
so maybe there's some inner connection
between all these kind of different
options were employing the structure of
the the forward transform that to again
it's speed up so
um
hey Chris I had a related question for
you I mean we've talked about this a
little bit but I know even thinking
about it you mentioned in your talk of
it
um so this is you know a kind of
compressed uh Quantum inspired linear
algebra but as you know there's other
proposals in the quantum literature for
like linear algebra I mean there's
famously you know this hhl algorithm but
then there's a lot of newer ones there's
this whole qsvt and everything and
um so do you have a sense of this is
kind of like hinting more about other
strategies to de-quantize certain cases
of those that's that's different from
the previous approaches that have been
pioneered and whether it's giving
insights about whether certain you know
special cases of those might be more
simulable than thought using tensor
networks say is the framework right
um
so I think so the the techniques I use
In this River is like very specific to
control transform because I have to
employ the lower lowering structure of
the sub Matrix OBT
um but you can sort of like uh for
example for opponent single value
transform is uh it has a very interest
structure of this repeating box you can
actually sort of model it as uh some
kind of information products and trade
tensor Network structure and you can
softly see some uh load line structure
from it too but if you have some
absorption on all the again how the
single value uh
um uh like distributes within this uh
block encoded operators
um but yeah I think I think it's like uh
discussion that's it's not very clear
like what uh when will this uh functions
are like compressible into MPS and or
like tensor Network in general so sorry
meaning some of this might have to be
empirical too for a while like just try
yeah
you just put the layers on an MPS or NPO
and just see that kind of thing too a
little bit
right
yeah just to uh quickly on this I think
the the success of qsvt which just uses
one seller qubit shows that the power of
this Quantum media algebra algorithm is
not on that particular single qubit but
on the Block encoding so if a certain uh
block encodings of some sparse matrices
or some other things can be decantised
efficiently I think this is something
that is uh what the literature hasn't
really exposed with too much previously
the the quantizations mostly dequantize
this Matrix polynomial structure the
result is like for certain problems the
polynomial order is low and therefore
you can de-quantize it in a black box
way but can you go into the details of
this block encoding and ask whether that
blocking coding can be quantized I think
that's a could be an interesting thing
to know
right
actually I have a personal question to
ask you Chris so did you think at some
moment that you've had because of this
that you had an efficient algorithm for
factoring and if so what did you do okay
right so actually we sort of discovered
this while simulating shorts so you're
sure we're just trying to see like what
happens for the environment and why
construct this operator for control so
always that's a low impact I just you
know decided to investigate why is the
case uh but after that I I mean I think
you know a sales implied sure sure
something is you know really similable
or not but uh everything about it so
it's like uh
so you you actually really need so both
input State and the operator to be
efficient so in short algorithm is like
uh the the input state to locality is
actually very expensive it's like the
Intel business of the order of the
period you'll try to find and for large
numbers you usually expect a very high
uh unvention so it's like uh yeah so
it's just like oh
it doesn't really I'll search yourself I
was thinking about that I just dropped
the idea of simple team uh yeah but it
could well be that all the entanglement
is because of swap Gates no
uh
oh no I meant I meant the state that
before the qrt so it's like you know uh
it's not it's not uh it's not like
French means you know like what if that
is just an accident of how sure if you
just put it in a different order
arbitrarily what if x you know what if
it's a hidden structure right you know
right
um
yeah that could be that's an interesting
thought but um
so the the shorts algorithm before
shorts I was like doing this uh uh
having this function map or the all the
unit the universal computation of all
these strings and surely for that
function for this this is like um
uh
it's like so I feel sort of generically
have this uh High entanglement uh
structure so it's not really about this
uh swap case but yeah but I think
oh yeah it's it's probably something
worse exploring as well
that's one comment I just wanted to make
I mean when Chris was talking about the
Genesis of the project
um that was something that was a bit
unsurprising for me in the end about the
whole project was because it was really
that he and Steve White were just trying
to simulate Shore's algorithm just to
see what would kind of what would happen
like at what part in the simulation
would your computer catch on fire was it
you know the first part or the second
part or what you know and then Chris
really honed in on this qft and kept
finding that it was very compressible
but what was really interesting to me in
the end personally was that it really
started out in this mode of like
simulating right where the um the idea
is that you the um the classical
computer is just trying to imitate this
very powerful quantum computer and we're
just seeing like how far it can sort of
keep up with the quantum computer but by
the end of the project I had almost the
reverse feeling in the end that like
almost like what the gift that Quantum
Computing might be giving us we thought
was a program to run on some futuristic
Hardware but what if it's just a program
that we run today you know like it's
like giving us programs we could run now
just on like a tensor Network substrate
and we just didn't see it that way so
it's like really the amazing work
happening in the 1990s was a family of
classical algorithms that they we just
thought you had to put them on on
special Hardware but maybe you don't
um you know so that was kind of the
feeling I came away with that was a bit
mind-bending for me because I'd always
just assumed when you see a Quantum
circuit the very next thing you do is
walk into a Quantum Computing lab and
put it in the in the hardware and that's
really what they're for I thought you
know but maybe maybe not always you know
so how about Grover
yeah look for the archive next week
because Grover you know Grover is a like
a even more extreme example of this
because you start with something that's
completely unentangled then you end with
something that's completely unentangled
and somewhere in the middle you have to
go through
um you have to climb up a hill right and
that's probably where the volume law uh
or like something like some high
entanglement structure will show up
but
um the punchline is that yeah it's very
similar to Shores in that way so there's
sort of two parts there's like the
Oracle which is a lot like the first
part of Shores roughly speaking where
there can be this very high entanglement
barrier in general so you know otherwise
like P would equal NP or something that
you know probably isn't true
um but then the other part the kind of
post-processing part which is roughly
like the qft its job is to extract the
answer out well Grover is what what
plays the role there it's just the kind
of outer part the loop of Rovers where
you just switch back and forth with this
diffuser and do all those kind of things
you mean in the phase estimation part
for for the latter part is it not really
transformation but just this kind of
overall framework of doing this sort of
two to the N over two steps
um that that part can basically be
de-quantized and that this was actually
already noticed in a PRL by Shalom
um where they just show that you can by
kind of thinking of an NPS
um in the same way like representing a
function you can kind of do like a
binary search algorithm on the function
like basically if you have a hidden
Delta function somewhere you could just
kind of integrate the left and integrate
the right and one of the integrals will
be zero and one of the integrals would
be one then you can just throw away the
side that's zero and then kind of zoom
and zoom in and zoom in so in very
efficient classical algorithm you can
like pick that value out actually so it
sort of has the same feeling as like
this qft Shores algorithm thing where
it's got two parts and one is very hard
in general and one is like classically
pretty easy actually
wow but you have to use an MPS that's
that's always the yeah in fact you can
do like even more
even easier say you get a sad problem
and you write your Clauses as as mpos
that you apply to an initial MPS that is
your uh
vehicle under this per position right of
all your configurations and then you can
see uh you can track the entanglement
and you see you see you have to go
um
over a hill and then come back down also
a paper by someone and um
[Music]
yeah
the uh the hope is always that you can
tunnel through that barrier somehow to
avoid
go vertically if you have if you were to
have a quantum computer
um you can do this you because you don't
care about building up entanglement but
uh
um yeah this I'm very interested in
right now too because there was two
papers last year I think I was maybe we
were chatting about this the other week
but one paper by this group like I think
it's Joel Morse group there at Berkeley
where they also looked at the qaoa
algorithm and they found that in many
cases there's an entanglement barrier so
it shows you that you really would need
a quantum computer to carry it out
um but then there's I forget the authors
I should have looked this up but there's
another paper that came out around the
same time last year where they just sort
of boldly tried to Tunnel through that
barrier by just capping the entanglement
by brute force and they found I don't
know how often I'd have to go look but
they found that in many cases if you
just did this tunneling kind of by force
you could still sample out a very good
solution at the end to the classical
problem so somehow it gives you the
feeling that the entanglement barriers
are very high but maybe maybe you don't
need all that entanglement you just need
some of it to solve that's right yeah
which part of the entanglement is useful
right because if you think about say
dmrg for like some algorithm that looks
for a ground state in MPS form then
Quantum fluctuations are really
important so you just don't just need
the dominant classical
configuration you need all of the
fluctuations to describe a state
properly but uh
in these problems we're looking at
decision or optimization we just care
about
one component or a few right so it means
that a lot of the entanglement is
actually not working for you it's just
there
like some byproduct of the details of
how the algorithm was written down you
mean something like that yeah
I see that in the in the Q a there's a
question that is actually very much
related to this that that goes about a
result of uh of Martin Van burenst that
that deals with universal Quantum
computation with with very few
entanglements so so as as far as I
remember but I'm not I'm not sure that
this is this this is exactly the the
answer to this question but but it is
clear that you can have a stage with
very very small arbitrary small uh
entanglement entropy that you cannot
approximate with matrix product States
it's actually a paper that we wrote
together with the Ignacio Syracuse that
that actually the the phenomenon entropy
is not is not
um it doesn't really care about the
small Schmidt coefficients and that's
why it's not uh it's not really kind of
of of good enough to to reveal all the
entanglements so indeed the small stuff
is very important sometimes and and what
you need to do then is typically use
Randy entropies with Alpha smaller than
one and these are actually well you know
Alpha goes to zero then this is really
the rank of your state but between zero
and one they have like the properties
that that are interesting and as far as
understand that any entropies of these
states actually are uh have lots of
entanglement but maybe somebody else uh
has a better view of of this or can can
also this question better
it was a great answer
I think it's a great answer yeah I mean
I think in practice when you try some of
this stuff out I mean Stefanos has been
trying new things out longer than I have
but one neat thing of course about MP
problems is that you can check your
answer at the End by sort of definition
of that class and um you can just try
you might observe a small entanglement
but if you if you then naively think
well it means I can truncate very
heavily you might just plug it into your
NP check at the end and just get a
totally terrible answer so you might
just find in practice you need a large
Bond Dimension which would tie back to
what you said Frank that it's just
telling you that the tails are important
in that case
oh great um
um
so maybe um well really nice to see you
uh Frank and miles and great to meet
meet you stephanus so this was a
wonderful panel you really brought this
subject to life in a wonderful way
um and uh thanks uh thanks Chris for a
great talk that was that was super clear
really nice very inspiring
um
oh thanks everyone inviting us congrats
Chris
okay anyway see you guys yeah great see
you again see another time